Here on the farm,
the hens are laying eggs again.
Usually in the winter,
they take a couple months off when it gets dark early.
That now that it stays lighter for longer,
they're laying eggs again,
which is really fun.
We're eating all the egg recipes that we can think of.
Today we are making a egg salad on sourdough bread.
So last night, I started the bread.
I just added my flour,
water, salt, and starter,
and then let it ferment in the fridge overnight.
Then I just the next day,
just dump it onto the counter,
shape it into the loaves,
let it sit, and then while it was sitting,
I drained my eggs,
added some really cold water into them afterwards,
and then we peeled them.
That's the girl's favorite part is peeling the eggs.
Then we added, like, a vinegar,
some salt, and little maple sugar to some celery,
and then we let that sit in the fridge to pickle.
While we finish the breads,
we did a final shaping of our.
Our loaves.
I'm loving the high protein farm flour with the sourdough bread.
I feel like it makes all the difference.
Then we put the loaves in the bread or in the fridge for a little bit
so they can get nice and firm for a score.
Then we scored the bread.
My. My goal today was to score the bread into, like a.
A daffodil shape.
And then while I was baking,
We added some shallots,
some Dijon mustard,
Greek yogurt, French salt and pepper,
and then we mix that up with our celery.
The bread turned out beautiful.
I definitely feel like it gave, like,
a daffodil vibe.
Daffodil vibe.
So that was a success.
We added the egg salad to the bread,
and that's what we had for lunch.
I realize, though,
that I am not a raw celery person like I always try to be,
but I never really am.
Luckily, the kids love the egg salad, though,
and they finished it up.